it does look as though for the first
time
in a very long time uh the democrats
candidate
is leading in uh the uh presidential
election
in georgia uh by a tiniest of margins
but nevertheless he is tell us more it
is a major moment
in the final stages of this presidential
race
joe biden uh has finally taken the lead
in georgia if that lead
persists and he doesn't lose it to
donald trump
and there is actually no suggestion that
he would he will win all 16 electoral
college votes taking him from
253 where he is currently to 269
that means that donald trump has no way
of winning this presidential election if
joe biden keeps his lead
in georgia there is a but and the but is
we might not be able to officially
declare it uh for some time
because it is so narrow the margins are
so tight
and there is quite a sizable absentee
military ballot that needs to be
counted in the coming days but this is a
very very significant moment
because it is a state that has been
republican read for many many years with
the exception of bill clinton in 1992
and georgia's son jimmy carter in 1980
and so for joe biden to capture georgia
is a big coup
and once the dust settles on this
election once everything has been
counted and fought over and agreed upon
it could be that states like georgia
turn it from being
a marginal victory into quite a sizeable
victory
for him but of course even if he does
win georgia it takes him to two six
nine so that's a draw that doesn't mean
that he
is necessarily in the white house but we
have to look at nevada
which is almost certainly going to go
his way we look at arizona where he's in
the lead at the moment we look at
pennsylvania which over the last couple
of hours
has been seeing donald trump's lead
quite
rapidly go down and down and you look at
the data and you drill down into the
county level
statistics and it would look very much
like that joe biden is on course in
pennsylvania
to win it uh quite comfortably okay some
time to go
yet i mean that is just as of a
projection if you like
but taking georgia takes him to
having one foot inside 1600 pennsylvania
avenue
it is a pivotal moment looking at that
the fact that
joe biden is in the lead for the first
time
in georgia if you'd looked at the map 24
48 hours ago you'd have thought that was
highly unlikely if not impossible
i think even the democrats would say
themselves that
um they put some effort into georgia i
mean they did put effort into georgia
that was on their target list
barack obama was down there uh
campaigning
for joe biden over the weekend preceding
the election
but it was one of those on their list
that
was a bit of a dream state to win if you
like and there are a number of those but
they will be very very pleased
if they can hold on to that lead and the
fact that the
direction of travel has been
consistently for the last few hours in
joe biden's favor and he has now tipped
the balance one thinks
he might manage to hold on to that okay
so that's the situation in georgia
looking at that map
north carolina just above georgia
too close to call hearing from ali that
is probably
probably going to stay republican
pennsylvania counting continuing
there in all likelihood according to ali
that could
probably go joe biden's way if we take
you over to the west coast
arizona still has to declare as does
nevada it could take up to another week
before we hear from
nevada arizona pretty close as well
but alaska of course their three
electoral college votes will go to the
president but the way things are looking
at the moment if if if joe biden managed
to hold on to his lead
in georgia it's all over for